good evening it's a case our 8 news now
investigators have covered four months
the woman at the center of it missing
until actually just hours ago thanks for
joining us here at six I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftus police were asking
for help finding the seven-time DUI
arrestee who several judges gave chances
to avoid prison eight news now
investigator David charns broke the
story and David this woman actually
writing into our eight news now Facebook
page that she would turn herself in
Denise she and police taking to the
comment section on our Facebook post
about the search for her we covered how
it took weeks for a judge to set bail
after her seventh DUI arrest tonight
she's behind bars again
and you have
substantial concerns regarding this
situation that we're dealing with here
the 8 news now investigators were the
only ones in court when a bailiff took
Mary and Reyes into custody in November
I'm assuming you're not asking me the uh
older anymore
weeks earlier Henderson Justice Court
Judge Sam Bateman told prosecutors he
couldn't set bail in what was then
reyes's seventh DUI arrest Because the
actual charging document was not yet
filed in August police arrested Reyes
for her sixth DUI since 2007 in that
August case police pulled Reyes over
hours after she was in court to close
out an earlier DUI case her fifth Thomas
Moscow is a former DUI prosecutor most
of those people an overwhelming majority
don't do DUI again their experience with
the system was harrowing enough for them
not to do it now for that small
percentage that do reoffend we have a
saying for them too most of them will
never stop Rey has accepted a plea deal
earlier this year sending her to a
treatment program and avoiding prison
time but records show she missed a court
appearance after a judge had already
admonished her with a two-day stay at
the Clark County Detention Center
Thursday night Metro Police issued an
alert asking for help finding her and
saying she had cut off her monitoring
bracelet a Facebook profile in reyes's
name then commented on the 8 news now
Facebook post saying the jail failed to
put a bracelet back on her when they
released her I never cut it off the
comment said An Officer cut it off when
I turned myself in they continued to
release me Metro then commenting back
then why not turn yourself in now let's
get this sorted out tonight
Metro says Reyes spoke to an officer
after that post last night and she did
agree to self-surrender this afternoon
which as you just heard she did we're
looking into that claim she made that
officers at CCDC cut off her bracelet
and released her without one we don't
know right now when she'll be back in
court but of course we'll be there I'm
David charns 8 news now Denise all right
so a final note here it took a judge
weeks to set bail as prosecutors were
waiting for Reyes his blood results
ultimately a judge did set the bail at
five thousand dollars and the DMV
revoked her license last summer